♪♪
>>> DEVELOPING THIS MORNING,
SOURS ARE TELLING CNN THAT
U.S. OFFICIALS ARE ACTIVELY
IN KABUL. THE AMERICAN EMBASSY
THEY'RE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR ESCATING
VIOLENCE IN THE GION WHILE
U.S. TROOPS NEAR COMPLETE
WITHDRAWAL FROM THE COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: JOHN AND BRIANNA,
WE ARE HERE AT BAGRAM AIR BASE.
THE FIRST TIME WE HAVE BEEN
GIVEN ACCESS TO THIS FACILITY
SINCE U.S. AND NATO FORCES
DEPARTED ON FRIDAY AND WHAT IS
WRAPPING UP BEHIND ME IS A
HIGH-LEVEL MEETING OF THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
DELEGATION CENTER BY ASHRAF
GHANI TO ASSIST WHAT THE
AMERICANS ACTUALLY LEFT HERE AT
BAGRAM AIR BASE AND HOW THE
AFGHANS CAN USE IT MOVING
FORWARD.
WE WERE TAKEN TO THE AIRFIELD,
THE RUNWAY, WHICH IS TWO MILES
LONG.
THIS WAS THE HEIGHT OF ACTIVITY
AT THE HEIGHT OF THIS WAR WHERE
FIGHTER JETS, CARGO PLANES AND
SURVEILLANCE AIRCRAFT WOULD
DEPART AND LAND CONSTANTLY.
IT IS NOW ABSOLUTELY DESERTED.
THERE ARE AIR HANGERS IN THE
BACKGROUND THAT HAVE BEEN
LOCKED.
THE AFGHAN STILL DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THEM.
AND THEN AROUND HERE, YOU CAN
SEE IT'S LIKE HUNDREDS OF CARS,
SUVs, PICKUP TRUCKS LEFT BY THE
AMERICANS FOR THE AFGHANS.
IT COMES AT A TIME WHERE THE
SECURITY SITUATION IN THIS
COUNTRY IS DETERIORATING
RAPIDLY.
WE KNOW THAT THE TALIBAN HAVE
TAKEN MORE THAN 150 DISTRICTS
JUST IN THE PAST TWO MONTHS.
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
AFGHANISTAN SAID THAT THERE ARE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
FLEEING THE COUNTRY SIDE BECAUSE
OF THE FIGHTING COMING TO THE
CITIES AND THAT WAS BACKED UP BY
THE UNITED NATIONS, WHICH SAID
MORE THAN 56,000 PEOPLE HAVE HAD
TO FLEE FOUR PROVINCES IN THE
NORTHEAST WHICH IS WHERE
FIGHTING IS EXTREMELY
AGGRESSIVE.
JOHN AND BRIANNA, BACK TO YOU.
>> ANNA CORNEN FROM AFGHANISTAN,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> NEW THIS MORNING, PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S WITHDRAWAL FROM THE
NEARLY 20-YEAR WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN MAY BE ALMOST
COMPLETE, BUT HOW IS HE GOING TO
STOP IT FROM ONCE AGAIN BECOMING
A SAFE HAVEN FOR TERRORISTS.
SOURCES TELL CNN HIS
ADMINISTRATION STILL HASN'T
FINALIZED ITS POLICY FOR
PURSUING TERRORISTS IN THE
COUNTRY ONCE U.S. TROOPS ARE
GONE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS.
I WILL SAY IT SEEMS LIKE
SOMETHING THAT PROBABLY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN FIGURED OUT BEFORE A
DRAW DOWN.
>> RIGHT.
SO, FOR MONTHS NOW THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
REVIEWING THE RULES, THE
STANDARDS THAT THE CIA AND THE
DOD HAVE TO OPERATE UNDER IN
ORDER TO USE LETHAL FORCE IN
AFGHANISTAN ONCE U.S. TROOPS
HAVE DEPARTED.
WHAT DO I MEAN BY LETHAL FORCE?
I'M TALKING ABOUT DRONE STRIKES.
EVEN POTENTIALLY COMMANDO RAIDS.
PART HOF THIS REVIEW IS LOOKING
AT WHETHER OR NOT TO RAISE THE
BAR, TIGHTEN UP THE RULES THAT
THE CIA AND DOD HAVE TO OPERATE
UNDER WHEN THE UNITED STATES IS
NO LONGER OFFICIALLY AT WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN.
AS YOU SUGGEST, THIS KIND OF
REVIEWING, THIS KIND OF
POLICY-MAKING PROCESS IS
EXPECTED TO BE AS THE UNITED
STATES DROPS DOWN IN THIS WAR
AND LIKE -- MOVES INTO A NEW
FOOTING.
BUT, IT IS NOTABLE THAT THIS
HASN'T HAPPENED YET, EVEN AS THE
WITHDRAWAL IS ACCELERATING,
WE'VE SEEN TROOPS LEAVING
BAGRAM, WE'VE SEEN TROOP MEMBERS
DROPPING TO THEIR LOWEST NUMBER
YET.
WHAT THAT MEANS IN THE SHORT
TERM, STATUS QUO CONTINUES.
DOD AND CIA CONTINUE TO OPERATE
UNDER ESSENTIALLY THE SAME RULES
THEY'VE BEEN OPERATING UNDER BUT
IT DOES LEAVE THEM IN A LITTLE
BIT OF A POSITION OF LIMBO AS
THEY SORT OF WAIT TO FIND OUT
WHAT THE RULES THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE PLAYING BY IN THE
LONG-TERM OR IN THE LONG RUN
ONCE AGAIN U.S. TROOPS ARE GONE
AND BIDEN IS SAYING THIS THING
IS OVER.
NOW, WHY DOES THIS SORT OF RULE
SETTING, POLICY PROCESS MATTER
IN AFGHANISTAN?
IT REALLY HIGHLIGHTS THE
DELICATE BALANCING ACT THAT
BIDEN IS TRYING TO STRIKE HERE
IN BETWEEN ENDING A WAR WITH AN
ADVERSARY THAT IS STILL FIGHTING
AND YET NOT LOSING CRITICAL
COUNTERTERRORISM CAPABILITIES IN
A COUNTRY WHERE THE UNITED
STATES IS STILL WORRIED ABOUT AL
QAEDA, STILL WORRIED ABOUT ISIS.
>> YOU'RE PURSUING ALL THESE
QUESTIONS, CONGRESS SAZ WELL.
HOW IS CONGRESS REACTING TO WHAT
SEEMS TO BE A LACK OF ANSWERS.
>> YEAH.
YOU'RE SEEING SOME GROWING
FRUSTRATION ON THE HILL FOR
MONTHS LAWMAKERS FROM BOTH
PARTIES HAVE REALLY BEEN PUSHING
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ON THE
NITTY-GRITTY, WHAT IS YOUR PLAN
TO CONTINUE TO PURSUE TERRORISTS
HERE AFTER YOU HAVE SORT OF LOST
VISIBILITY INTO THE COUNTRY.
AGAIN, REMEMBER, WHEN YOU PULL
OUT CONVENTIONAL TROOPS FROM
AFGHANISTAN, YOU REALLY LOSE THE
BACKBONE THAT AMERICA'S
INTELLIGENCE NETWORK IN
AFGHANISTAN HAS BEEN BUILT ON
FOR THE LAST 20 YEARS.
SO THEY'VE LOST A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF VISIBILITY OF
CAPABILITY TO SORT OF SEE AND
THEN CARRY OUT LETHAL STRIKES
THERE.
SO I THINK YOU WILL CONTINUE TO
SEE CONGRESS PUSHING F